well four days after one of the largest
fires in our city's history dozens
downtown still left without a place to
live now people across our community
stepping up to help them gathering food
clothes necessities sasha loftis live in
studio she visited one of the donation
sites today joins us with more on the
movement
brian this fire destroyed so much and it
took hours to put out it also left so
many people with nothing but the clothes
on their backs now others are helping
them move forward
it was absolutely crazy to be honest
soot-covered walls shattered windows and
piles of rubble
after the largest fire las vegas has
seen in 25 years we got a knock on the
door and we have to run out dozens are
still without a home thank you so much
now the community is stepping up to help
everybody was talking about how we
needed to do something ashanti mcgee and
fawn douglas organize this donation
drive gathering necessities for those
who have lost everything we just
immediately started
putting
our resources together and trying to
figure out who we knew and try to reach
out to
other organizations to figure out what
we could do they wrapped up their
week-long effort thursday now these
supplies are going to the organization
united movement organized kindness so
they can be distributed we need to do
something to to step in you know because
this is our this is our neighborhood
countless lives were changed sunday in a
matter of minutes it's just
unimaginable like what what people are
going through but with the help these
people are providing those struggling
can begin to recover we live here and
this is our these are our peoples
now shanti and fonz say they did receive
monetary donations as well those are
going to the red cross to get to those
families if you'd like to help we have
more information on our website
8newsnow.com